私は来週から受給とで死にそう
じゃあめちゃんしそうですタイトルにもある通りなんですけども
[音楽]
ame
混ぜるぞ宇宙をチャンネル闘茶ランキング
ょうざーいにだよしたーー
ああああああああ
うーんそうな比例してないそんな気にしてないんですけど
意義素忙しくてなかなか動画が撮れなくてありがたいことにいろんなお仕事してて生
配信でたり沖縄に行ったりしてちょっとまだ私はなかなかドーンとれないんですけども
まぁ日本になっててもう
さらに向かれて今歳までなってしまって特に取れる位置もないかなと思ったんですけど
も
.からず利用されるものの気持ちをぜひともみなさんに共感していただきたいと思って
とっておりますなかなかこういう状況の人の気持ちないと思うんであのって喋らして
ください結構2週間前ぐらいにも描かれてるっぽくて
チャンネル登録者ランキングって伸びるんですけども三井が散っラインさせん
210万円そして兄が
ある専門 ic チャンネル915万人そして妻が私の一つは9003万人ということ
で
されました
別にいいんですけどでついいんですあのー
普通に悔しいですねあ c デスクやすいですけどすごいなるけどキッズチャンネルの
1球が本当にすごい5位と22言うですねちょっと特殊な条店があるんですけど俺
ちゃんねる等ですねからじゃバイ再生回数の動画を必ず持ってるんですよ僕が1番再生
されての組の動画で直に戦犯開催するもなんですけどこの一度兄のお二人はもう
go クエ再生と金森わけがわからないもうね大宇宙今日でバズったんじゃないか
みたいなどうぞて保持しておりまして
そうそこかなって気が失せですもんなんか半永久的に再生されるヤバイ動画を持って
いるこれ
オーダーしつつっぽいです私もそんなただあの水場所だけがいかずいろんな一応見てる
んですけどそこはデカイですねこんなカス近いうち
new 切るような動画をこうだしてるって言う印象がすごいありましただがその1
ついてなかったけどね気にしないんですけどもても言われると気に入っちゃいますね
たまに
はじめあの抜かれちゃったよみたいなこと言われてああ
枯れたんだみたいな感じでちょっと言われると若干気にするところがありますね
素直に悔しいですね服安いんですけど僕のチャンネルスター人増えてはいるんでまあ
仕方ないなと思いつつも今後も承知して参りたいとポロってりやき
ブーブー言い合区さと母だろさてどう
が作ろう登って作れませんから本当にすごいと思う
あとネエことばたぜかすぐに可愛い俺より可愛いも動かしずに頑張るしかないんで今後
も頑張らせていただきます
あの特に人になった時と大きな神秘を取って変化はないかなとちょっと5位が遠ざかっ
たかなっていう悲しい気持ちはありますそんぐらいかな
抜かれたチャンネルがもうねチャンネルと
も残留がちがうね本文にマルチクリエイターというかも散ってチャンネルなんですぎ
ないても手ではあるんですけどもそっちこれだけあの言いたかったんですけどそのに前
に流れとチャンネルねこうなんか僕がの動画だしてがちょっとこうなんかいう方が増え
たっぽくて夢でそれはちょっと僕の言い方が悪かった部分はあったと思います
bleach ませんにんになりましたっていう動画で5分で言いたかったのは
チャンネーぞろカスをし表現して突然抜かれたからびっくりしちゃって話なんですけど
それでなんかこちらせいただいて
な伝わり方しちゃってそれでこうちょっと心ないコメントされる方が入ったってみたい
なんでそういうのはやめてください
ジュは計何かいうの良くないですよチャンネル登録せず買ったかってないとそれなら俺
も知らんし事実かどうかわかんないんですよもしそういうことしてるんだったら
変化 google さんの坂に動くと思うんで何買う我々が嫌がっ体格いうことでは
ないです
ちょっと寝ようかもよって俺がこれを言うことで
なんかそういう酷い事が起きてるって実は広まるのもちょっと嫌だったんですけど
たまにメッセージ一さんやめさせてくださいとかあなたのせいでこうなってますよ
るって言うんですけど僕は一切そういういいとたいしそういうことをしてほしくないし
憶測で誰かのことを悪く言うのはぜひ食べていただきたいと思っております
がれたのは悔しいんですけどそれをさなんか
抜いた人にどうこう言うのもおかしな話ですもし僕多い
してくれてる人が成功しているのであれまあそういう力があるんだったらぜひあの僕の
ことを応援する方に負けていただきたいと思っておりますて音試合じゃないね頭に
乗り上げ
まあ俺も含めて他の人なんですけども悪く言うのやめてあげてほしい
好きな人応援するだけであーと日本第3位はおっしゃっております a という感じで
ちょっとね前回の電池になったってどう
はちょっと雑件そういう話が違っちゃったんでちょっとちゃんと言っとかなきゃなと
思ったよせていただきましたらないというわけでさぁ
いうかまぁ同盟なるですからまだまだ銅メダル南寧
たらいいかに盛り返していくかちょっとねまずにかけて頑張って行きたいと思います
これずっとね最近ほんと別の仕事が多くてありがたいことなんですけどもうちょっと
落ち着いたらまた youtube
頑張りたいと思います東京の部屋をねちょっといいな訳あってなかなかまた撮影できる
環境が整ってないんで楽しみにしててください
4月
宜しくお願いします以上さんいかがでしたばいばーいいっ
あっは
[音楽]
blr